I finally did it I bought every dual
sense controller for the PS5 the OG
white was followed up by midnight black
and Cosmic red then came the Starlight
blue Galactic purple and this delicious
Nova pink then the much love gray camo
arrived quickly followed by the God of
War Ragnarok limited edition bringing
back that PlayStation blue next the long
awaited Pro Controller known as The Edge
arrived before Hogwarts Legacy Put a
Spell on Gamers even a region specific
Japan only Final Fantasy 16 dual sense
released which was tough to get my hands
on and look at this LeBron James got his
own controller Spider-Man 2's iconic
design arrived in September 2023 before
the latest series The Deep Earth
collection a metallic threesome of
cobalt blue volcanic red and sterling
silver that's 15 dual sense controllers
what are your top three